ce samedi matin à la patinoire de dijon
c'est le ballet des parents qui
accompagnent leurs enfants aux cours de
danse sur glace ou de hockey dans le
milieu du patinage après les révélations
des derniers jours l'ambiance est tendue
mais ici au club
les parents ne voient pas d'impact on en
parle nous entre nous comme ça mais
voilà parce que c'est un sujet
d'actualité mais par rapport à ici on ne
sent pas de problème quoi on n'a pas eu
de déco on n'a pas été informé y a rien
eu vraiment c'est transparent bon sens
pas impacter parce que c'est pas issing
après voilà je sais qu'il peut voilà on
et personne n'est à l'abri mais en tout
cas pas ici pour le moment et pas de
souci des membres de l'académie des
glaces de dijon nous ont confirmé qu'à
l'époque où l'ex entraîneur travail est
au club
les problèmes avaient été réglés par
l'encadrement et l'homme démis de ses
fonctions en 2006 il a ensuite été
plusieurs fois mis en cause dans des
enquêtes pour harcèlement ou d'agression
sexuelle est condamné en 2016 à dijon à
18 mois de prison avec sursis également
kinésithérapeute
il aurait exercé dans la région
notamment dans un centre médical de
dijon sa trace se perd à ce haut lieu où
ils résident ray serait désormais sans
emploi il n'a plus le droit d'encadrer
des jeunes et plusieurs clubs de sport
assure d'être averti de son passé